[Laughter]
why does it sound like me
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey I'm Hannah and I'm the world's okay
his mom and I love family trips I live
for the time that the kids get off
school cuz I just love to go all out and
plan so much fun stuff for us to do but
I realized for every family trip I'm the
one doing all the planning so I decided
for our next upcoming family trip that
was a fly in my face it's okay
so I decided for our next upcoming
family trip I would give the kids full
reign over planning it I mean every
aspect of it would be up to them any
family time is quality time right we'll
see we ought to start off with the rolls
on this one
because I couldn't sense this getting a
little out of control first and foremost
we're on a budget we're not just this
unlimited flow of cash family so
unfortunately no space excursions no
trips to the moon I don't even know if
those are available yet but those are
definitely off the table second we got
to keep it safe we can't be doing
anything extremely dangerous for this
trip so no shark diving
no jungle ziplining and last no-repeat'
trips I feel like if they pick a trip
that we've already done it's not gonna
be as exciting for them because they
already know what to expect so we're
gonna do something new for this and all
experience it for the first time
together
all right boys I have a surprise for you
we are gonna go on a trip you guys get
to pick whatever we do for this trip do
you know what you're gonna wait where
are you going where are you guys you
guys need to clean your room this is a
mess so Jackson hands me this page
ripped out from a Travel Magazine and
after a reverse Google image search we
figured out that it is in fact the Grand
Canyon so Wyatt this is where you want
to go how are you gonna get there a
travel guy with a car okay so we will
take a road trip to the Grand Canyon
so it seems like it's not that expensive
of a trip but after Matt and I added up
all the expenses in total of the whole
trip it ended up looking like it was out
of our budget so Matt and I came up with
a solution are you ready guys okay open
your eyes that's what we're taking on
our trip we surprised them with an RV
because why not we are gonna take an RV
to the Grand Canyon sleep in it cook in
it live in it I don't know if any of you
guys have seen a goofy movie but it's
one of my favorite movies of all time
and this just it gives me such goofy
movie vibes the most wholesome family
vacation I could ever think of and we're
off how you feeling that good since the
kids were in control for this trip I
decided to ask each one if there was an
activity they wanted to do on the way
and what about you Jackson
some crystals
oh my gosh if you guys know me you know
how I feel about crystals love me some
crystals we luckily found this place
perfectly along the way where you can
break open your own geodes and they have
a huge selection and you can choose
whichever one you want and it was so
much fun
keep going to keep pushing just to see
Jackson have that fascination and be so
excited about something that I'm so
excited about it felt really cool now I
have someone to gift my crystals to when
I die why I had kids we are back on the
road this is so cool
wow this is amazing so we found a
campsite and walked along the river I
got eaten alive by five thousand
mosquitoes over all day one was really
great well itchy for me but a really
great hey Wyatt
where would you really like to stop on
this trip one day you and go swimming so
we found the most amazing spot on the
way to the Grand Canyon it's a rock
waterslide because we're looking for
somewhere for Wyatt to swim it's like a
natural rock waterslide with a pool and
it's in Sedona okay this water is
ice-cold but Jackson you still want to
go on the slide it's free
yeah I realize no that I was screaming
the whole way down in the moment I
didn't notice and I probably could have
lived my life just not knowing that that
happened but we have video evidence so
there we go
i'ma what I know we stated that
rockslide for a long time the kids had a
blast it was so cool so memorable just
this place that we'll never forget
back in the RV we are headed to the
Grand Canyon so we went from Red Rock
Desert to like over-the-top beautiful
forest mother nature be slaying us right
now
so we finally arrived at the Grand
Canyon and it's too late to go actually
see the Grand Canyon so we found the
last RV campsite with full hookups
within the park and the boys really want
to do s'mores so we're gonna try to find
some charcoal to make s'mores tonight
now I want to take this moment to give a
shout out to that not only did he do all
the driving but he handled everything
regarding the RV look at you go you're
so dad so he took care of all of it he
managed to hook up our RV to get us
water and electricity which was so
awesome nice and dumped the PE what are
you doing
I am going to connect the waste hose
[Music]
okay guys we have our snow s'mores
skewers and we went to the store and we
got some charcoal are you ready for
s'mores yes how's your nose yes good
okay it was one of those evenings that
was just the most perfect weather where
you can sit outside in like a sweatshirt
and pants and you feel a little bit cold
but not too cold and you're making
s'mores and my kids were just living
their best lives how is it great he's a
great but that night was seriously it
was so simple yet so epic for all of us
good morning everyone so day three if we
woke up super early and decided to rent
bikes that day because you know my kids
they don't want to walk and they luckily
have this awesome bike rental place
where you can get trailers for your kids
to sit in that attached to the bike so
mountain I each got one who each towed a
child and took the bike path around the
side of the Grand Canyon
oh my gosh oh my gosh you guys it is
unreal otherworldly you look at it and
you're like there's no way that this is
real there's no way that this is on this
planet and this is real life and I sound
like such a dork right now but I'm
serious side note I shoot the series on
my phone I cannot to the Grand Canyon
full justice but at least you guys get a
little peek at what we were experiencing
say cheese cheese white hot stuff
[Music]
and another cheese now if your kids are
like mine the things that they typically
get excited about our video games or
cartoons or stuff with loud music or
very very bright colors just being there
in the Grand Canyon with my kids jaws
just dropped in awe really proved to me
that nature always wins nothing beats
being outside with your family
experiencing something so cool this is
amazing so at the end of this day we
were exhausted we saw so much and
experienced everything we possibly could
so we just went back to the campsite and
chilled out ate a little and went to
sleep and as we were falling asleep
it started to thunderstorm training
yeah
[Applause]
he's the most cuddly in the morning
let's say bye to the Grand Canyon
bye Grand Canyon you guys ready to go
home
so I think we can all agree here that
the drive home for money road trip is
kind of the worst part so I was totally
open to any and all stops that the boys
wanted to make because anything to delay
having to do this boring Drive so we're
in Nevada the boys keep singing Viva Las
Vegas I don't know where they write that
song
you want to go to Las Vegas okay in the
spirit of letting the kids control this
trip we're gonna we're gonna do it let's
stop so we get to Vegas we find an RV
park thank goodness
and we decided to check out the strip so
we first started looking for some
kid-friendly games to do and stuff do
you like that like arcade okay we had a
massive dinner and it's late for us at
least it's way past their bedtimes and I
think we're just quickly realizing that
we can't do Vegas the way that we used
to at that point we were so exhausted I
mean we've been goin goin goin goin goin
for days and so we just went back to the
RV and went to sleep and that was the
end of day four
now it's my turn to try be so happy
about that
we'd rock star beyond
we're headed back to our house so we
made it home in one piece
no breakdown no big big big drama but a
lot of memories the first thing I
learned was vacation mode Hannah is 100%
my dad I did all the things that my dad
used to do on our family trips that bug
the crap out of me when I was a kid I
made unnecessary commentary about
everything in nature we saw these are
bad I constantly ask my kids where we
were what we were doing and if they were
excited guys are you excited to be here
and I continuously game very mundane
updates about our trip oh my gosh
my butt is numb and sweaty
so dad if you're watching this which I
know you are this is a heartfelt and
sincere apology for always getting
annoyed with you for doing that to me on
every family trip and last I mean on
this trip huh no no don't do it
I always cry I'm not gonna cry in this
episode for me thinking back on that
trip like I know that this is the best
time of my life I can't do it
looking back on this trip I realized and
I recognize that this time is gonna be
the best time of my life
I just want to bottle these moments and
I just want to make them Walker going by
so fast these are the memories that you
know when I'm old this is what I'm gonna
look back at as the highlight of my life
I know it's bittersweet you know but
when you're a parent you small kids
things happen so fast and things change
so quickly that I just want to hit a
pause button so badly and just
experience more of it get it together
girl I'm so grateful with that we had
the opportunity to do this I know that
this is not something that everybody
just gets to do and so being able to do
this I heard every second but I think
that as a family it brought us a lot
closer dang it that was like ugly cry -
oh that wasn't even like sweet tears
that was full-blown ugly cry oh so
that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
and if you had a memorable trip that you
took with your family write about it in
the comments let's all just make each
other cry or you can text me this is a
real number and I do read each and every
text I don't get to respond to them all
but I do read every single one now if
you'll excuse me I have five days worth
of clothes and sheets to wash so I'm
gonna get my laundry on well next time
[Music]
Wyatt you're so unbanned right now
[Music]